Scott Disick doesn't seem to be coping
well with Kourtney Kardashian's new
romance he's your boyfriend
[Music]
in the latest episode of Keeping Up with
the Kardashians Kourtney reveals the
sister Khloe how her ex Scott called her
to discuss their dating lives last night
Scott called me at like 2:00 in the
morning Jo which he never calls me late
at night ever
he was just like ranting like what are
we doing in life what are you doing what
am i doing
I'll go but what are you doing and no or
then he'll say but what are you doing is
it any better
Kourt K is currently in a relationship
with units Benjamin while Scott has been
dating 19 year old model Sophia Ricci by
the end of the conversation I just was
like I have a boyfriend he's 24 years
old it's not the craziest thing that's
ever happened in the world and so he was
like he's your boyfriend and then he's a
trigger and then he hung up the phone
Oh Kourt
a source told ET back in July 34
year-old Scott was having a hard time
seeing Kourtney with her new man quote
it's never an easy thing to watch
someone you share three children with
and so many memories move on with
someone else it's tough sometimes you're
not getting over right oh I mean I feel
like I would never be over her
[Music]